yeah do I need a haircut
hey guys we saw the Meg ha we did we saw
it you know that movie where you were
like hey I want to see if some fun
stupid giant shark action and r-rated
material nope I'm gonna make this review
super short for you right now
it is a pg-13 almost bloodless non feast
of a lot of boredom the way I feel now
is how I felt when I was watching it I
kind of want to do one of those red
letter media videos where we just
uploaded a black screen for
yeah Jay what did you think about the
Meg well Mike he thought it was flat I
don't know I was unmoved by much of
anything and I was bummed out cuz I saw
the trailer and I was like I don't know
this is gonna turn out but at least
maybe it looks like it could be
attempting to be fun and silly and it's
not really that silly intentionally and
it's not really that silly
unintentionally either is this kind of
stuff happens and it's a bit of a mess
and the cast is fine to see them getting
a little submarine this is your movie I
kept watching it going why did they cast
Jason Statham yeah he doesn't have tough
guy line he can't really fight a shark
you can't fight the shark like they even
say that if you're living through an
actual shark encounter one way to
deflect them is to pop him on the nose
and I thought maybe they'll be silly and
at least go for that but no especially
because of the fact that a lot of how
they work to take on the shark is how
they would go about take it on a regular
yeah this movie is not something where
we felt the need to write any notes
because we feel nothing for this movie
normally we do a review we try to be as
concise and articulate as possible all
we're gonna do is express to you how
myth this film was this is another one
of those 50 I think it's got 51 on run
tomatoes and I really think it fits that
mold because for me it's kind of a flat
like a straight line mouth yeah heard
some people say it's pretty fun and I've
heard other people say it's pretty flat
is it I don't think so I don't think so
it's but I don't even think it's funny
but you might it could have been so bad
it's good but it doesn't even earn that
bad here's what it really felt like to
me this is based on a novel that
apparently people really like apparently
it's a good novel or at least a popular
I'm watching a movie as I was watching I
was going it feels like they shot one
movie we're
they tried making an actual good movie
and then they did reshoots
and edits they're like well maybe we can
make this into so bad it's good but it
doesn't commit enough to its seriousness
to the point where you can take it
seriously and it doesn't commit enough
to it schlock and kam penis to the point
where you've walk out feeling like it's
a fun time doesn't reach the heights of
deep blue sea or sharknado both movies
that were mentioned on the movie fights
episode I did recently where the first
question was on that episode besides the
original jaws which is a pretty
what's the all-time greatest shark movie
go check that out yeah I just don't
think that this film is worth watching
if I'm being honest I don't really know
who this would be for unless you're a
fan of like the sci-fi channel it will
place so much better on a TV which is
weird because you see this it's the
[ __ ] lid on so you assume this would
play great at least on a big screen you
know I got the biggest laugh when
someone farted in theater and I was so
bored I was so bored I didn't even laugh
at that when everyone was laughing I was
just like whatever it's kind of sad yeah
just felt like a bit of a hodgepodge it
kind of meanders cloth feels really
random yeah I don't hate this movie I
don't I just feel anything for it feel
nothing well I was going on in the movie
before the Meg showed up I turned to you
and I said there's too much other stuff
that has no emotion in here that I could
care less about can we just get to the
Megalodon and get to some shark girls
and the shark girls are not that
thrilling I've done Google Image
searches for just the word Megalodon and
the first row of things is usually a lot
more jarring and unsettling than most
anything that I saw in this yeah it's
this terrifying idea a shark that big if
you look up this movie Jason Statham for
sure thought he was signing up for an
r-rated flick yeah and I've read a whole
interview with him on Collider where it
just seemed like he didn't realize
could it be pg-13 and is not happy with
this film if you committed a strong
language vulgarity hard are violence it
would have made up for so much instead
you just kind of got a whatever film
when you're doing with a megladon yeah
none of the characters are strong enough
that you can just care about that
journey on its own and then the meg
isn't used enough to really be that
scary or thrilling there's a lot of
really wacky logic in the movie
ultimately it feels like kind of a waste
of what could have been a really fun
time like I don't know there are a
couple jokes here and there and that's
about it for like the fun factor nice
movie there was one moment in the film
where Rainn Wilson has made one comment
that made the whole theater laughing
including me and I thought oh this is
when the film's gonna finally really
commit to the schlock enos the kam penis
and then we're gonna have a good time
sure it's been like 45 minutes but
whatever the rest of the film can be
this way I'm cool but now you kind of
get a lot of boring character scenes and
it really is there's drags everything is
stuck you kind of understand all the
characters are taken from the playbook
most of the motivations and plot lines
are taken out of the playbook doesn't
really do anything of its own very much
and that Rainn Wilson moment was like
one of a handful throughout the entire
movie where all the elements on-screen
coalesced to make me I feel like I was
truly watching a movie and the rest of
the time I felt like I was waiting for a
movie to kick in Jason Statham - this is
that movie that would have worked better
with the rock in the lead in some ways
because there's a certain type of energy
and charisma that would match a movie
more like the Met kind of like how the
rock matches more for rampage Jason
Statham's like delivery in this film he
seems like he's really trying to do a
good job and technically he's doing all
right
actually he's Jason Statham and my
introduction of Jason Statham was films
like snatch and lock stock where I've
knew him as an actor before an action
lead so I know the guy can really act
I'm like this kind of know everyone's
acting should be more campy to try to
like this should have just committed to
that's why I mean they seem like they
try making a good movie then through
editing and Reese
they're like no we got to try to make
this a schlocky campy film but it
doesn't really commit to either side so
instead you kind of got yeah whatever
yeah you get this movie that doesn't
ultimately come up with a tone at all it
just feels like a bunch of scenes that
all kind of flow at the same pace yeah
and occasionally there's a joke yes and
the big reason why I think this movie
has moments that are unintentionally bad
and then some that are intentionally bad
a lot of it hinges on the opening of
this movie which is so serious a monster
movie it's like so serious and obviously
I wasn't even sure what was happening
with him opening the way with you
okay you got Jesus a 'litham here who's
clearly trying to give a more serious
performance you got cliff Curtis in here
who's a great dramatic actor Ruby Rose
who's not known for camp each locky
comedy and by the way she's hot as hell
Ruby Rose Ruby roses like so hot yes she
is
although whatever was going on with her
hairdo distracted me like half the moon
why she's got that like cool person hair
in your eyes like wet look and I'm like
you're sitting at a computer for half
the time like why why do you look like
you just got out of a fight she's Ruby
Rose no like it's not I'm just saying
like it kept me like what's up with you
you had a couple other fun ish
supporting characters who would have
been fun in a movie that knew how to
have fun don't worry guys we're not
overthink you know we were just telling
you we were pretty bored this is like a
fun run Tomatoes so I can fully see some
people coming out of this being like I
don't know what you're talking about I
had a good time but I just didn't have
that time we didn't go on 40x by imagine
if you go on for DX you'll probably have
a good time yeah i don't know i mean
these movies are always fascinating to
me because I rarely walk out of a movie
unmoved at all and I also know that with
a movie like this it makes me curious
for what somebody else might see in it
because I have just seen other opinions
of people who had a time I wish I had
any kind of time underwhelming cool
shark though a lot of Asian actors
though Chinese there's some Thailand
stuff in there too acknowledging a
different movie goes to China now just
like sometimes it's justified well other
times I'm like you just trying to get
that Chinese market at you yeah the
prologue of the movie wraps up you you
doing this big old shot over the water
coming in on Shanghai and I was like oh
here's why they thought this anyway like
this review is done I think this reviews
mostly done I don't know now we're just
looking for things Jeremy Jones is right
though that all that Beach stuff with
all those people in the water that
doesn't happen to like the very end of
the movies if you're going for that kind
of stuff you're gonna wait around if
there's a trailer moments that really
stood out to you that looked appealing
that moment has to at least be fun in
yada yada yada the thing though is a lot
of the fun of that would probably work
better if you skip to those things
there's such a such a meandering journey
to get to those fun moments in the
trailer that when you get there they
just don't feel as fun cuz it kind of
felt like a slugfest to get there yeah
dog moments good the bloodiest scene in
the entire movie oh right there they
don't much John wick that dog yeah like
times five it's crazy yeah and then the
dog comes back at the end like a zombie
and fights the shark it's perfect don't
spoil the like zombie - don't spoil the
I'm sorry I didn't mean it guys the dogs
hashtag safe Pippin yeah there are four
people wearing safe Pippen t-shirts in
the road farthest oh okay talking about
me while you're a bet which you got to
do is subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell all our
movie reviews are done this way check us
on patreon bullying TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is Jason Statham biceps bye